[Música]
muy buenas tardes quiero comenzar yo mi
intervención haciéndoles una pregunta
bien sencilla quien de ustedes levante
la mano por favor está buscando en este
momento de su vida la felicidad
eso más o menos lo imaginaba bueno no sé
si ustedes que levantaron la mano y los
que no levantaron la mano habían
escuchado de un psiquiatra y neurólogo
víctor frank este cuate era tan bueno y
era tan resiliente tan fregona que tuvo
la oportunidad o se las ingenió para
escapar de 2
en campos de concentración en la segunda
guerra mundial después escribió algo
bien atinado que a mí me encanta
platicar en las conferencias sobre
felicidad y él decía no sé si ustedes se
acuerdan cuando estaban pequeños y
pequeñas que la felicidad era como una
mariposa que sucedía cuando ustedes
estaban pequeños y pequeñas y trataban
de atrapar esa mariposa pues obviamente
se iba la asusta vamos y como no tenemos
alas pues obviamente no la podemos
alcanzar pero qué pasaba en esa infancia
cuando ustedes se sentaban cuando
ustedes se calmaban y empezaban a
disfrutar cada una de las cosas que
estaba a su alrededor empezaban a sentir
la brisa en su rostro empezaban a ir a
oírlos los sonidos de los animales los
sonidos del ambiente inclusive empezaban
a disfrutar a la misma gente con la que
convivían alrededor esa mariposa
inmediatamente iba ahí se posaba en su
mano precisamente eso es la felicidad
ahora la felicidad y es lo que vengo yo
a compartirte el día de hoy en lo que he
aprendido en este largo viaje para
descifrar el código de la felicidad es
que la felicidad la vivimos día a día la
felicidad no es algo que buscamos porque
si la tratamos de buscar se nos va a ir
la vida entera para encontrarla y yo
precisamente en ese viaje
la famosa búsqueda de la felicidad pues
me di cuenta que para descifrar el
código había tres elementos muy
importantes que todos podemos practicar
día a día y el primer elemento se les va
a ser muy extraño esto que tengo aquí a
mi alrededor porque el primer elemento
es algo más o menos así que todos
tenemos lamentablemente aquí la gente de
la producción pues medio uno que no
huele tan bien y ahorita que lo veo me
doy cuenta que es mío entonces el quemón
es para mí pero es precisamente esto que
tengo yo aquí en mis manos qué significa
esto el ponerme en los zapatos de los
demás el ser empático el preocuparme
siempre por el menos favorecido
el que no sabe tanto el que tiene menos
que tú eso es lo más importante porque
no soy yo loco que se los estoy diciendo
ahorita aquí enfrente más de 1600
estudios de las mejores universidades en
el mundo nos dicen que el ser amable con
el prójimo que el ser amable con el
vecino con el compañero con el familiar
es lo primero que te va a ayudar a ti
para vivir esa felicidad como lo
comprobé yo muy sencillo tuve la
oportunidad o tengo la oportunidad casi
todos los días de acudir a algo a lo que
los gobiernos en sus planes de
desarrollo establecen como
y polígonos de pobreza qué significa
esto que ahí vive realmente gente que
tiene mucha carencia es decir ahorita en
lo poquito que nos alcanzó a ver a
ustedes veo hay alguien que tiene
relojes de marca hasta que alcanzó a ver
la marca veo quién tiene gorra vio quién
tiene lentes veo que traen playeras
blusas hay cámaras inclusive si yo les
dijera levanten en el celular todos van
a levantar un celular en aquellos
lugares olvídense que tengan eso lo malo
más que pueden aspirar es a unas
tortillas y frijoles para comer pero no
todos tienen cama donde dormir no todos
tienen útiles escolares para ir a la
escuela mucho menos tienen un vehículo
para ir a la escuela y son familias muy
grandes que viven en casas muy pequeñas
que sucede con esto que lo que vamos
nosotros ahí a platicar es precisamente
a recordarle a la gente que aprender a
pesar de las circunstancias que están
enmarcando su vida así como las
circunstancias que están marcando la
vida tuya ahorita
se puede salir adelante y cuál es el
primer punto generar las condiciones
idóneas para salir adelante y qué es
esto un simple abrazo un abrazo que dure
de 5 a 7 segundos carga la energía y te
das cuenta que así como tú estás
sufriendo al acercarte a otra persona y
verla a los ojos te das cuenta que esa
persona también está sufriendo y te das
cuenta que se ha que la queja lo mismo
que le duele lo mismo pero a la vez a
veces ves brillo en los ojos y significa
que también disfrutan las cosas como tú
eso es bien bien importante para
descifrar ese código de la felicidad
porque si ustedes leen el periódico
ahorita más del 80% de las noticias
tienen una connotación negativa qué
quiere decir esto que vemos puro crimen
porque vemos puro crimen porque le
estamos perdiendo le hemos perdido
el valor a la vida y necesitamos volver
a dárselo como lo podemos hacer si tú
tienes hijos ahorita que están aquí o
nos están viendo si tú convives este con
con mucha gente sobre todo con pequeños
abrazan los no dejes pasar ninguna
oportunidad para abrazarlos y decirles
que los amas un simple gesto como ese
cambia al mundo aunque se oiga muy de
cliché eso es lo más importante y aquí
me doy cuenta también yo en este famoso
estudio de la felicidad y recorrido que
había en bután no sé si conozcan bután a
alguien que denominaron el rey loco hace
45 años y este cuate estaba tan loco que
decidió cuando lo nombran rey decide
despojarse de todos los privilegios e
irse a vivir a las faldas del himalaya
porque porque él inventa una política
pública que yo siento que todos
deberíamos de tener en nuestra vida que
se llamaba la felicidad interna bruta es
decir ella no se media nada más lo
material y el bienestar económico
él descubrió en su aislamiento que
necesitaba tener contacto con el medio
ambiente necesitaba tener contacto con
él mismo una introspectiva pero también
necesitaba porque no también necesitaba
recurso el chiste de esto es que tenía
que haber un equilibrio entre todas las
partes cuando a los de bután que es una
nación de no más de 700 mil habitantes
que se encuentra entre dos de las
potencias ya sea a nivel económico o
industrial como la india y como china
cuando llegan con los butaneses y les
preguntan te consideras un ser humano
feliz el 53 por ciento de ellos
contestan que se consideran muy feliz
el otro 45% se considera feliz y sólo un
2% si las cuentas no me fallan decía que
no eran felices que estaban haciendo los
butaneses bien que no estamos haciendo
en el resto del mundo estaban midiendo
la felicidad interna bruta y a ti que me
estás escuchando el día de hoy te invito
a que precisamente implantes o bueno más
bien que empieces a utilizar esa
política en tu vida o ese término porque
te va a llevar a la satisfacción pero
así como el zapato que tengo ahí que ya
descubrieron ustedes el primer punto
para descifrar el código de la felicidad
tengo este
bonito aquí que yo creo alguno de
ustedes alguna vez vio cuando estaban en
la infancia
esto significa cuando yo estaba pasando
en una de las etapas más difíciles de mi
vida que no tenemos tiempo para platicar
la pero me sentí arrinconado me sentía
que no podía por causalidad no
casualidad me encontré con una
metodología que se denomina yoga de la
risa qué significa esto que yo no
necesito nunca algún estímulo externo
para reír para carcajearme para sonreír
lo único que necesito que es tomar la
decisión propia poner un pie afuera de
mi cama y decidir reír a carcajadas como
yo quiera les platico la historia este
monito éste elefantito es de un niño que
yo conocí hace muchísimos años que se
llama carlos les voy a pedir antes de
esto que se rían todos por favor
ríanse a todos
brillante más fuerte
ok así como este
carlos cuando tenía tres años carlitos
vivía en un pueblo pequeño que sucede
cuando eres de un pueblo pequeño conoces
a toda la gente del pueblo se reúnen los
domingos en aquella ocasión pues o eran
católicos se reunían los domingos y ahí
es donde veían a toda la gente
venían a los primos veían a los maestros
veían a la familia de la vecina total
que empieza el servicio y empiezan a
cantar el coro para que entre el padre
con todo el séquito entonces va pasando
el padre y en eso a uno de los de los
niños que le ayudaban se le ocurre pisar
le las sotanas que creen que le pasó al
padre
casi se cae no se rompió los dientes de
puro milagro pero se dio cuenta el
pueblo entero que el padre tenía
peluquín
qué sucede con esto que todo mundo se
quedó serio porque el padre era
autoridad en el pueblo pero que creen
quiso carlitos se atacó de risa como
nunca todo el mundo lo voltea a ver su
papá le dio una cachetada a su mamá le
dio un coscorrón los hermanos le dieron
un pellizco qué mensaje se llevó ese día
carlitos a su casa que era malo reírse
en lo que es natural pero carlitos como
era esos cuates que se carcajea na gusto
como la mayoría de ustedes creció
cumplió seis años entró a la primaria y
un invierno que le estaban poniendo un
examen estaba contenta contestando un
examen y tenía su compañerita lado a la
compañerita se le ocurre estornudar qué
sucede cuando estornuda a la compañerita
se le sale un moco pero la niña está tan
concentrada que no se daba cuenta
respiraba y el moco subía y bajaba que
creen que hizo carlitos se atacó de risa
como nunca porque todavía lo tenía pero
llegó la maestra y le dio un reglazo y
lo reprobó lo castigó y lo mandaron a su
casa total cuando carlitos cumplió 15
40-50 años y le dice ríete carlitos no
se puede reír si tu convives con niños
te quiero invitar ahorita que hamás
condiciones su risa porque cuando le
pregunten a los 20 30 40 50 años o
cuando le pidan que se rien no va a
encontrar ningún motivo para reírse
porque nosotros les suprimimos esa risa
estos señores no es tan peligroso porque
hay una manera de reprogramarlos para
reír pónganse de pie todos por favor
rápido si son tan amables
un niño antes de cumplir cuatro meses un
bebé todavía no sabe reírse carcajearse
entonces qué es lo que hace un niño
balbucea un niño quiere encontrar todas
las maneras para poder expresar esa
alegría si me alcanzan a ver ustedes les
voy a poner un ejemplo un niño balbucea
más o menos así entonces hoy tienen la
oportunidad de reprogramarse aquí en el
teatro de los héroes que vamos a hacer
quiero que voltean a ver a la persona de
la derecha los que tengan sino el que
tengan más cerquita pónganse de frente
por favor rápido le van a agarrar los
cachetes y van a empezar a balbucear a
la una a las dos a las tres
y ahora la persona de la izquierda
rápidamente
agarre la orejita agarre de todo ahí
estamos balbuceando si ya terminaron se
sientan por favor si son tan amables
ustedes el día de hoy se están llevando
la segunda herramienta para descifrar el
código de la felicidad ya no se pueden
parar de reír acá cual es la segunda
herramienta reírnos si no te puedes reír
empieza a balbucear haz ejercicios cinco
minutos al día en el espejo aunque tu
señora aunque tu novio aunque tus hijos
digan que estás loco escóndete te vas
con un espejo y empiezas a balbucear
frente al espejo gadala cuál es el
secreto de la felicidad en este punto
que tú estás engañando a tu cerebro a lo
mejor ese día recibiste una noticia muy
negativa a lo mejor perdiste a un ser
querido a lo mejor perdiste un empleo
sin embargo tu cerebro no tiene por qué
enterarse si tú te empiezas a reír lo
engañas de tal manera que si lo haces
como hábito tu cerebro se cree que eres
la persona más feliz
del mundo y para finalizar lo pongo aquí
para que lo vean y sea gráfico y se los
aprendan el número 3 y esto es bien
importante y es posiblemente el que más
trabajo nos cueste
no vamos a decir que vamos a tomar agua
qué significa esto aprendí que el tercer
punto para descifrar el código de la
felicidad y vivir esa felicidad era
precisamente el perdón es decir el amor
puro el amor maduro el amor dice que se
siente cómo le hacemos para perdonar que
aprendí yo que para perdonar no se
necesitan dos partes cuántas partes se
necesitará una lo único que necesitas
para perdonar a una persona una relación
interpersonal que tú sientes que te
defraudaron que te traicionaron o
simplemente todo es cuestión de
expectativas que tenemos de la gente a
la gente nosotros la subimos en un
pedestal y no la queremos bajar de ahí
que sucede que cuando nos falla una vez
ese superhéroe o esa superheroína todo
se acaba y es ahí cuando guardamos el
rencor
entonces el rencor se trata nada más de
una sola cosa que tengas las
herramientas la posibilidad y la
disposición de soltar obviamente no vas
a cometer los mismos errores otra vez
pero necesitas soltar y para finalizar
mi participación aquí con ustedes este
me encantaría mencionar por esto es esta
por eso es esta botella el tercer punto
una metáfora budista que a mí me encanta
y dice así imagínense todos los que
estamos aquí todos los que nos están
viendo que esta botella en su corazón si
se fijan está llena de agua qué sucede
si yo te está puesto botella y agarro de
por aquí un puño así de este puño de sal
se lo he hecho la revuelvo
y le doy un sorbo que va a suceder lo
más seguro es que esta agua pues la voy
a escupir nada más que no la voy a
escupir aquí porque no me gusta porque
porque está muy salada porque no tuvo la
posibilidad de distribuirse porque es
muy poquita agua ahora ese su corazón
en el perdón y en el amor verdadero su
corazón no debe de ser de ese tamaño
su corazón debe de ser del tamaño de
todo este auditorio imaginemos que
llenamos este auditorio de agua
obviamente lo sacamos a ustedes primero
no se asusten llenamos todo este
auditorio de agua llego yo por arriba y
luego vacío esta botella y otra vez la
llenó a este auditorio le echamos el
lleno de agua le echamos el mismo puño
de sal la revolvemos así como pudimos
entre mucha gente llegó yo agarro un
puñito de agua y me la tomo esa agua no
va a saber obviamente a sal porque
porque ese corazón fue tan grande que
tuvo la posibilidad de aceptar todas
esas defectos que le vemos a las
personas a nuestra pareja a nuestros
hijos a nuestros vecinos compañeros de
trabajo lo acepto con el tiempo lo fui
lo fue diluyendo y transformando hasta
que finalmente tuvimos la posibilidad de
perdonar y vivir
ese amor verdadero esta es el tercer
punto para descifrar el código de la
felicidad así es de que ya sabiendo
cuándo son los tres puntos para vivir
esta felicidad te quiero hacer una
última pregunta posiblemente la pregunta
más importante que te vayas a hacer tú
en tu vida y esta es tú
estás buscando la felicidad o mejor la
vives muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]